la demande pour les minéraux critiques
entre autres ceux qui servent à
fabriquer les batteries pour électrifier
nos transports augmentent sans cesse ce
qui est de mieux à de plus en plus de
débats entourant la protection du
territoire au Canada la Loi sur les
mines signifie que l'exploitation
minière après séance sur des activités
comme l'agriculture ou d'autres formes
d'utilisation du territoire pas facile
donc pour des citoyens et des
municipalités de faire valoir leurs
droits face à de futurs projets miniers
[Musique]
nous on est vraiment tombé en amour avec
la forêt on a une belle biodiversité
c'est la forêt que j'ai toujours rêvé
d'avoir puis ici on a trouvé vraiment la
place qu'on cherchait
depuis maintenant deux ans Julie Tessier
et Étienne Poirier développe leur projet
de rêve dans le canton de clevelun en
Estrie une ferme et un immense terrain
qui contient une grande forêt de
feuillus pour eux c'est du potentiel
plein la vue
un lieu propice pour la série culture
puis une belle forêt en santé avec des
belles érables productives une belle
pente qui nous amène l'eau jusqu'à
cabane on peut pas demander mieux
on rêvait d'agriculture on en a fait on
prenait le rêve de nos parents
et là et là qu'est-ce qui arrive
c'est un peu une note qui se réalise
mais voilà que tout ce projet pourrait
être compromis car ce qu'il y a sous ses
arbres cette ferme et cette terre et
peut-être convoitée leur terre comme
plusieurs autres dans la région et sous
l'emprise de titres miniers
ici on voit la pancarte là c'est écrit
danger puis de mine c'est qu'à autrefois
aller en extrait du cuivre ici est-ce
qu'il y en reste dans le sous-sol on
sait pas vraiment pas
des histoires de conflits entre la
présence de clés miniers et d'autres
usages du territoire on en voit de plus
en plus au Québec parce que il y a un
engouement mondial pour les différents
métaux et minéraux
Hugo Lapointe et porte-parole de la
Coalition pour que le Québec est
meilleur mine il mène la bataille depuis
des années contre les pouvoirs
exceptionnels octroyés aux minières vous
avez un chalet vous avez une maison vous
avez une ferme vous êtes propriétaire de
la surface mais vous n'êtes pas
propriétaire du sous-sol
n'importe qui aujourd'hui en ligne sur
le système du ministère des Ressources
naturelles
peut à ce qu'on appelle du click and
clim avec une carte de crédit à peu près
60 dollars on peut aller cliner
n'importe à quelle parcelle du Québec
et quand on a un clim ça nous donne le
droit sur ces ressources minérales là
pendant deux ans
en sein des possédés
on sent qu'on a perdu le contrôle dans
le fond on perd le contrôle
de notre propre terrain
nos voisins ont presque toute choisi
pour le paysage
la quiétude
malgré le reposition les citoyens ne
peuvent rien faire exceptés de refuser
l'accès à un promoteur qui veut faire de
l'exploration sur leur terrain mais un
voisin peut en décider autrement les
municipalités ont aussi les mains liés
car la Loi sur les mines ne leur octroie
aucun pouvoir d'interdiction de projet
minier
donc c'est comme si on laissait tout à
l'entrepreneur minier
et que si jamais le gouvernement voulait
intervenir mais le gouvernement s'expose
à des poursuites de la part des
entreprises minières
[Musique]
graines ville sur la route depuis plus
de 10 ans ce village des Basses
Laurentides se bat contre Canada carbone
une minière de Colombie-Britannique qui
veut développer ici une mine de
graphites ainsi qu'une carrière de
marbre il faut rappeler d'ailleurs que
la minière poursuit la municipalité de
greneville sur la rouge endommage et
intérêt pour 96 millions de dollars et
96 millions c'est beaucoup d'argent pour
un village en fait qui compte à peine
2800 personnes on a utilisé des
ressources financières de
l'administralité pour l'engager des
avocats professionnels pour nous aider à
trouver un moyen pour protéger nos
intérêts ça a été à la course supérieure
ça a été à la cour d'appel et puis
finalement on a réglé encore avec une
entente
la minière a finalement pu poursuivre
l'étude de son projet mais le cas de
grainesville sur la rouge a lancé un
débat sur le peu de pouvoir des
municipalités face aux grands projets
miniers on a institutionnalisé ce régime
du club minier là il y a plus de 150 ans
maintenant d'abord l'industrie n'était
pas celle qu'elle est aujourd'hui
c'était pas ça il est 150 ans on n'avait
pas les lois environnementales et les
sensibilités environnementales qu'on a
aujourd'hui non plus on reconnaissait
pas du tout les droits tochtones par
exemple ou les autres occupants du
territoire donc il y a un anachronisme
entre le régime minier instaurer 150 ans
et les réalités les valeurs
d'aujourd'hui
depuis 2016 il y a toutefois eu un
changement la création des thiams les
territoires incompatibles à l'activité
minière une municipalité régionale de
comté peut demander au gouvernement
provincial à ce qu'un territoire ne
puisse être exploré les critères
d'admissibilité sont en revanche très
restreint il se résume principalement à
des zones d'urbanisées
on n'est pas capable de protéger des
lacs au Québec avec des chalets autour
s'il y a pas suffisamment de chalet vous
n'êtes pas protégé de l'activité minière
on n'est pas capable de protéger des
ondes touristiques des monts où il y a
beaucoup d'activités récréaux
touristiques on n'est pas capable on
n'est pas capable de protéger des
territoires agricoles convenablement en
région rurale ou forestière obtenir un
Thiam et très difficile seul le
territoire agricole
considéré comme très dynamique peut être
admissible à un Thiam ce n'est pas le
cas dans le canton de Cleveland et ce
n'est pas le cas non plus à Greenville
sur la rouge ou l'agriculture est
davantage agroforestière et en plus dès
qu'un titre mini est actif sur un
territoire qui pourrait être jugé
incompatible le promoteur minier a un
droit acquis
[Musique]
c'est souvent la présence de clés
miniers ou de prospecteur
d'entrepreneurs miniers qui déclenche
l'action des citoyens l'action
municipale donc c'est trop tardif il
faut comprendre que pour une
municipalité qui nous écoute là si vous
envoyez une lettre demain matin au
ministère des Affaires municipales en
désignant avec la MRC votre MRC en
désignant un territoire compatible
activité minière en 24 heures 48 heures
ils vont geler le territoire pour poker
l'acquisition de nouveaux clim durant le
temps que vous faites votre travail
[Musique]
la graineville sur la rouge face à
l'incapacité d'obtenir un Thiam on a
décidé d'utiliser l'une des dernières
cartes dans le jeu contestez une demande
de la minière auprès de la CPTAQ la
Commission de protection du territoire
agricole la CPE
un rôle de s'assurer qu'il protège le
territoire agricole
[Musique]
la CPTA Q devra décider si elle accorde
ou non une dérogation de zonage pour de
l'activité minière en territoire
agricole la minière a déposé à la CPTAQ
un rapport d'expertise pour appuyer sa
demande à son tour la municipalité a dû
débourser pour faire une
contre-expertise le débat ne fait que
continuer
à date peut-être un peu plus que 600 000
$ pour protéger nos intérêts
mais ça devrait pas être à nous de payer
pour ces choses là
nos lois il y a besoin des grosses
corrections
l'industrie minière au Québec ce n'est
pas banal c'est source de développement
économiques pour plusieurs régions c'est
pourquoi depuis longtemps le
gouvernement favorise l'investissement
et l'exploration minière Canada carbone
comme tous les prospecteurs disent agir
dans le plein respect des règles en
place oui il faut faire du développement
minier au Québec on va continuer de le
faire mais il faut le faire
intelligemment il faut le faire aux bons
endroits les bonnes mines aux bons
endroits vous savez les terres agricoles
au Québec c'est 5% du territoire
donc protéger 5% du territoire du Québec
est-ce que c'est trop demander
[Musique]
dans le canton de Cleveland Julie
Tessier et Étienne Poirier sont
peut-être loin de grainesville sur la
rouge et de ses enjeux mais ce qu'il
voit les inquiets il craignent de devoir
emprunter un jour le même chemin
moi je pense qu'on devrait favoriser des
projets rassembleurs comme l'agriculture
de proximité des choses comme ça plutôt
que des projets qui divisent des forêts
comme celle là des grandes forêts c'est
des lieux qui
qu'on a besoin de protéger
[Musique]
la croissance économique est encouragée
on achète à l'infini mais on est
peut-être un peu de notre environnement
moi ce que je souhaite collectivement
toutes les Québécois on se disait on
mérite mieux que ça
[Musique]